when I was a kid I thought the funniest
person in the whole world was my big
brother Jack he was so funny and
original I used to laugh till I cried
when he did a routine of his he called
guzzlers Jin Benny had a character
Klemke diddle Hopper and another one
called the mean widowed kid he was
really funny then one day we got a TV
set and I saw Red Skelton stole all my
brothers material but you know what he
did it better here he is the king of the
clowns my big brother Jack I mean Red
Skelton
thank you very much and it's really an
honor to be here with the industry when
it thanks its lucky stars and if any of
you feel that though you've been
forgotten just remember whistlers father
it's nice to be asked here everyone
backstage saying gee you look good
that's one of the three ages of man
youth middle agent gee you look good
they have asked me to present the sound
Awards and I think that's appropriate
for a man who does pantomime but in the
early days of the motion pictures when
sound first came in it was on the vitae
graph and it was on discs and not always
did the give me my hat we're be yeah
why it's first time I've ever worked
with a net
the young that was on a disk and always
not always did the sound match the film
and the actions I remember one picture
that I saw this cowboy he rides up and
he speaks to an Indian Maiden
howdy I'm back I want you to know that I
love you and we're going to get married
I don't care what people say I know
there's a lot of people that don't
believe in mixed marriages but we'll
make it work and maybe when our kids
come along we can start a whole new race
of people I brought you a gift
but when it came on the screen on the
desk it didn't exactly match the action
it was more of something like this
hi dear I'm back and I don't care what
people say we're gonna get married I
know a lot of people don't believe in
mixed marriages but maybe when our kids
come along we can start a whole new race
of people
a lot of progress has been made with
sound but still there are the people
even tonight possibly than the winners
come up as much as they know about this
they'll all walk up and do the same
thing I always get a kick out of people
when they when they talk on the
microphones you ever notice the first
fellow when he makes his speech in a big
convention of anything the first fellow
always have trouble the microphones
these guys mm-hmm we ready to start hey
Sean can you folks hear all right out
there testing one two
little wet but it's all mm at this time
we would like for you to me is this dawn
could you turn it up a little I don't
think it's loud enough could you turn it
up just a little bit
there's a horrible way to go through
life but did you ever see these fellows
who have trouble with the microphones
when they go dead on them ladies and
gentlemen at this time would like for
you to meet a very lovely lady
Helene Krauss and tonight
what's the matter with the damn thing we
could
we'd like
when they shove it an ashcan
then you always have people who forget
what they're going to say and they
become very nervous they
they had a frog in my throat
then you have the experts that know how
to use their voice and control it they
know when to talk loud and when to get
dramatic and how far to stay away from
the microphones Anaya ladies and
gentlemen tonight we like to meet a
fellow who's been in your community for
good many years this man is honest
this man is sincere this man
oh well I gives you an idea what I was
trying to talk about anyhow
for the accomplishments achieved in
sound oh by the way I don't need these
glasses but I've reached the age where
curiosity is greater than vanity for all
the president's men
Arthur piano doe see less fresh hole
dick Alexandre and Jim Webb for King
Kong Harry Warren tech tree William
McCoy Erin Rochin and Jack Solomon rocky
Harry Warren
Tedric William McCoy
these guys work all the time
nearly shy laugh myself sometimes they
keep getting lonesome you know that lion
Burbridge and bud Alford for Silver
Streak Donald Mitchell Douglas Williams
Richard Tyler and how Ethington for a
star is born Robert Newton or Knutson
dan Wallen Robert grass and Tom Overton
and the winter farewell to arms
all of the presidents men
I have a long I have a long list of
people to thank but I'll save it to give
it to you later
for now thank you all the Copeland's
Thank You Alan Pakula thank you robert
redford thank you I can't say enough I
can only say what Harvey said before
thank to everybody it's really pleasure
I'd like to thank Kathy burrows Richard
burrows and Dave Horton for their super
sound effects job and I'd like to thank
the county thank you what to thank the
Academy my colleagues for the job they
did Alan Pakula and all the wonderful
people at Wildwood art Levinson who
started me on the project Robert Redford
and last but not least my sound partner
Chris McLaughlin who I with whom I truly
share this award thank you
you